[Music]
on today's show we take my favorite call
of all time it's heavy and it's hard and
we take a deep dive into generational
trauma and what it looks like to be
strong courageous stare down family
legacy and say we're making changes
starting now stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up what's up this is john
with a dr john dolone's show i'm still
getting dressed here
james is in a hurry
it's all about james hey we're so glad
you're here
if this is your first time listening to
the show you don't even know who james
is none of us do hey we're this is a
show about your mental health your
relationships about life we're so glad
that you've joined us we've got a packed
house out there in the studio and by
packed house we mean like four people
but it's so good
to see y'all um oh there's another guy
over there and he's like hey i
he actually got out of the shot well
played man hey uh thanks for joining us
if you want to be on the show give me a
shout at 1-844-693-3291
or go to johndaloni.com
ask johndolooney.com
ask
so hey how are you guys doing
doing pretty good yeah yeah awesome
and james i'm doing great so great
that it's time for the conversation
starter
cards we have them this time
so i got the john dolonie starter cards
yes
yes half of them just say ask me
anything so that
would go very open-ended but today's is
if you could only eat one meal for the
rest of your life what would it be pez
cherry flavored pes no question about it
just kidding that's from stand by me if
you knew that you'd be the greatest
person ever but i could tell by look on
your face
you didn't really give me a whole lot of
time to
identify it all right what meal would
you have
i would have
jasmine
my favorite thai restaurant i would have
their soy sauce noodles with chicken and
a spring roll
two spring rolls he's two spring rolls
pretty specific
and for the listener yes he does have
severe ocd and that's what we work with
and live with what about you kelly
um there is a restaurant here called
perry's that has these pork chops that
it's the best thing i've ever eaten yeah
by far and normally i would have said
steak but these things are amazing so it
would have to be
those pork chops i think my la my death
romeo has always been and living the
life that
i grew up with we always just kind of
just in case right um
i think it'd be a big crawfish boil a
big crab crawfish boil they dump it out
and you just eat until you can't feel
your face
and then in my scenario they kill you
after that right but that's that's what
i would do and
wait a good way to go
sounds like a viking crawfish boil
[Laughter]
that's the kind i like
viking crawfish boil and new orleans
crawfish boils are very similar but if
we are on an island we know that you
would die
because
yeah so for
for you folks listening the other day on
the internet somebody asked who would
live the longest on a
desert island me james or
kelly and clearly there's no question
about this james and i at some point
would fall asleep at which point kelly
would murder us in our sleep and kelly
would win
you would live the longest i i don't
deny any of that
james would be the first to go
there would be no record of us having
ever existed because kelly is so into
murder podcasts
there would be none of you found
it would just be yeah wiped out the face
of the earth oh good unless i'm glad hey
we are starting off this podcast on a
positive note so that's so great
so good
all right hey where can people find
these cards
um they're on the internets right
they're on somewhere i've got a paper
here that tells us oh yeah yeah okay so
listen
uh hey we're actually we had we had a
meeting yesterday and i'm excited about
this
they're gonna be ready in time for the
holidays one for
adult couples one for um grown-ups and
kids and then one for
your families like when you go to
wherever it is you're going to travel
for the holidays conversation cards that
are going to help you they're they're
100
politics and covet free you're going to
be able to have regular conversations or
new ones that you haven't had in a year
with people that you're gonna be stuck
with or that you choose to be with
uh it's gonna be like what's the worst
boundary your mother-in-law has ever
crossed with you and a family one and
then it's gonna have in parentheses
stared directly at your mother-in-law
and her eyes go like that right but it's
man it'll be awesome you can go to
conversation text conversation to 33789
and i think there's like 20 of them in
there that you can
practice being a human before you go
meet with your mother-in-law or your
kids or whatever but go to text
conversation to three three seven eight
nine and then we are working these
working on these cards and we will have
them out soon i'm excited about that all
right let's go to the phones let's go to
sherry in grand rapids sherry what in
the world are you doing this morning how
are you good morning john thanks for
taking my call thank you for calling and
it is early bird there so thanks for
being up with us so what's up how can i
help
my mom is a child holocaust survivor she
was born in hiding
kind of born under a barn and you know
at the time you know there's there's
very little food there's no medicine no
doctors a ton of trauma and
no psychiatric care right
so she's a refugee to the us as a
teenager um and we really believe that
she developed her you know some severe
bipolar and some schizophrenic kind of
manic delusional
things from all that trauma
so she's you know fearful of of soldiers
and police and and uh you know uh
christian pastors and priests those kind
of people yeah and you know
unfortunately she was a pretty awful
parent
so
we experienced some you know the
homelessness the divorce hunger and
neglect or the really extreme survivor
behaviors
so fast forward i'm now an adult
and i have her in like this adult
supervised nursing home care i have to
care for her she still has those manic
delusions occasionally and they are
starting to scare my teenage daughters
i understand her trauma i mean that
generational trauma i get
why
but i have so much
resentment i think maybe anger
that
i i have to care for her that even
though she was
you know this terrible parent and i know
why
though i'm just looking for suggestions
for those of us that have these mentally
ill parents that
that maybe didn't care for us but we are
caring for now wow that's
man number one thank you for your trust
that's a that's a big one do you mind if
we spend some time unpacking this
yeah
um
it was
man it was a few months ago
that a study came out and i don't even i
don't even know where the study is so it
may not even be real data but
um
that a number of high school kids
millions of high school kids middle
school kids across the country have no
understanding they've got no reference
point for the holocaust it might as well
be 500 years ago might as well be
dinosaurs right
and
for me when i saw this i remember
thinking that's a shock because my
granddad was involved in that and that's
just that was the other day right
especially when you look on like a
timeline of earth that was literally a
few minutes ago
so
walk us through
the the stories that you know your mom's
experience she was born in a barn so
talk about what that occupation was like
what her childhood was like
and so my grandparents were in their
young 20s a newly married couple they
had a little daughter and he was an
accountant and they were just living
their life in an apartment like everyone
else in germany right
no they were in the netherlands they had
no coffee
occupied by um the nazis had occupied
and they didn't think nobody thought
that someone their neighbors were going
to come for them no one thought and they
wore their stars because they were
slowly starting to require and at one
point
they were warned they're gonna you know
they're starting to round people up you
need to be prepared and sure enough they
got a knock on the door and the story
you know they ultimately were able to
escape
my aunt went into hiding with other
families and they always took the
children separate from the parents to
protect them and my grandparents
were hidden in several different places
before landing on a farm with this
really really brave young christian
family like in their 20s had like a
seven-year-old son
and they took in my family knowing it
would be certain death if they were
found yeah so just just to put in
contact so jewish family in hiding they
first had to start wearing stars right
so to know
they couldn't go to the stores walking
on the street everybody had to be able
to point to them and say we know who you
are
well and you couldn't you weren't
allowed to go to public schools anymore
you couldn't go to the to the theaters
you weren't allowed to have certain jobs
and eventually it became that almost
everything was controlled and then they
just started rounding people up and you
have to understand if you like so i
would say right now if if we got a
government mandate that i had to start
wearing a star my first thought would be
i'm just not going to do it and we have
it's so far from the where we live right
now you have to understand that
anybody could stop you at any time and
say let me see your origin papers and
they could shoot you in the street if
you didn't have your star on and just
keep walking right um it's a world that
we can't even imagine right now and that
note gets thrown around a lot we have no
no
picture modern picture of this right now
and so then you move to
yeah then that news starts tightening
literally and
um
like it starts to suffocate and then
they start rounding people up so then a
family on a farm as you mentioned
if nazi soldiers came to a family farm
and found that they were harboring
um
hiding jewish families
they're executed on the spot right and
their farms everyone would have been and
you know the butchers had to be in on it
the baker had to be in on it on these
towns these whole towns had to be so
brave to
know that they were hiding and so my mom
is born there so you have a baby the
soldiers would come periodically to take
supplies or to search and it was a very
scary and it was years of hiding like
that so you i've heard of families um
especially early on when code first
started and we just didn't have even a
grasp of how big it was and then a
couple would find themselves pregnant
and the fear they had just how that
discomfort
imagine hiding out
in a barn and people are actively
hunting you
and then you find out you're pregnant
right so your
grandmother finds out she's pregnant and
your mother that maternal stress and so
what i'm trying to build is an arc here
there's a lot of emergent scholarship
showing that
mental illness often starts with
maternal stress in utero right
and so imagine you're being hunted
literally by your neighbors you find out
you're pregnant and you give birth to a
baby in a barn right
and then walk us through there so your
mother your mother's born is an infant
and imagine
people knocking on the door to come
search your house and you've got an
infant that you can't tell they're gonna
scream or they're gonna cry or they need
to have their diaper change right so
you're trying to
live that life
and then your mother grows up how
the
they had to figure out who was still
alive what family's there they had to
find their their first daughter that
they had put in hiding and
and then you know they're my
grandparents they lost almost every
brother and sister they lost all their
parents and they found that they had two
nieces that survived that had been
hidden
and so now they went from a family that
they had just been a family of one and
now they became they found their other
daughter they had two nieces they had my
mom
and
there's still no job there's no
transportation there's still
anti-semitism so they had to find
housing and there was this constant fear
that they were coming back yeah yeah and
pause on that
imagine having a seven-year-old and a
four-year-old
and i've got it i'll do it with just me
i got a 10 year old right now i got 11.
he's 11 and a five-year-old and imagine
me and my wife are being hunted in our
own neighborhood
and i have to take my 11 year old and my
five-year-old and give them to another
family just in case we're caught they
won't kill all of us
and this isn't just a few people this is
millions and millions of people
and so i don't know where my kids are
there's no texting there's no email i
just have to give them to somebody else
and hope
they've got a better shot than i do
i just to wrap my head around that my
son just came home from camp after being
gone for a week
and the first day was pretty awesome you
know what i mean i didn't have to give
anybody any snacks
and then the second day was kind of cool
you know
and then by day three and four and five
like we're all kind of moping around the
house missing our son there's a there's
a key part there's a key member of our
of our crew that's going right
can you imagine hitting them off and
saying best of luck and i hope i see i
just can't wrap my head around that
and suddenly your parents when this
thing's quote unquote supposedly over
which you trust anybody at this point
right your neighbors have been hunting
you and then there's an announcement
it's all over
right you know what i mean yeah right
so your parents your mother
is a toddler here she finds she's
they're just trying to round up and just
connect families any way you can
there's no way to get food there's no
jobs no anything and when do they so
that she grows up like this right where
are we gonna get food where are we gonna
what are we gonna do thinking of the
stress of parents
then what
it took him a few years to to be able to
find housing to get stable and then my
grandfather insisted that he wanted to
move to america and then we had they
started the immigration process which
takes a quite a few years and then you
once again you have to sell everything
yeah and you have to leave everything
behind and you have language barriers
and knowledge and education barriers and
so the entire family got on a boat well
the last generation to sail into new
york to see the statue of liberty and my
mom was 12.
and on a boat coming to america with no
english and
in this idea
we don't know what's over there but it
has to be better than here so everybody
grab a bag and we'll get on a boat and
we're just heading
quote unquote that away and we have to
remember there was no google there was
no
maps there was no books
you're talking about getting on a boat
and going just somewhere
we don't like moving to a new town
right like what what what church are we
going to go to what friends are we going
to have what movie theaters are how
close is public's gonna be you're
talking about millions of people who got
on a boat and just said wherever there
is is better than here
right and what a 12 12 year old
man
so you take all that stress all of that
and that's not just stress like hey dad
got laid off it's stressed like like we
said your neighbors are hunting you and
now we're just gonna leave our land
we're gonna show up to a strange place
um we don't speak the language we don't
know any of the the quote unquote
cultural rules we know none of these
things and then what then they settle in
and then like many immigrant families
they just went to work hard right
that's exactly right the older kids
you know that six the older
aunt cousins were
16 and they went to work and my
grandfather went and found a job and
the younger kids there's another kid by
this point and they tried to go to
school tried to assimilate and
you just did the best you could and you
know some of them no one talked about
trauma no one talked about no one talked
about it at all it was not no one looked
at the past it was too hard and too
tough and everyone just kind of went
their ways
so let's fast forward here so your mom
has you you got brothers and sisters
i have two older brothers two older
brothers there's three of you
and did your mom
get married she find somebody she loved
how did that she
she really kind of ran so she found
someone
um you know an atheist someone and he we
moved to the middle of you know really
far away from from her family out kind
of in the middle of nowhere and
uh
you know they they were very volatile
she you know she obviously had mental
illness back then
um and he had alcohol problems so they
they had this very tumultuous it really
was pretty bad and they ultimately
divorced um when i was 12. so at this
point she mentally ill she doesn't have
job skills she is still in english is
still not her first language
and
there's no support structure partially
because
she's afraid
everything of the government she's
afraid of you know i was going to be
taken away she was afraid you know and
the boys ended up kind of doing their
own thing and they were a little older
than me and they went off and became
very adult very quickly on their own
with other people
and i
you know became to some extent her
cohort her um
her caretaker you know as we
should she had some serious survivors
abilities i mean so she would manipulate
men to to have a place to stay and to
have money and she would you know we
would go from church to church looking
for you know
food and aid and you know we would
always be on the go because
she was afraid they would take me away
so she you know if
people found out how we were living or
you know we didn't have money or we were
sleeping in our car
and and she would steal or she would lie
or she would do and then she would just
have these manic episodes where she was
so afraid
of the police and some people coming to
get her
um the paranoia
so she was she was a tough parent right
she was oh my gosh you grew up in a you
grew up in a swimming pool of trauma
right i mean it i can't imagine if
you've ever taken the aces the adverse
childhood experiences
scale have you ever taken that
i did what are you seven or eight
i'm a seven seven yeah
and you know what that means for you
downstream right
i do i know that there's gonna be some
potentially serious and i
i know i have i'm going to have health
issues no matter what probably because
of generational trauma and i'm trying
very hard not to pass that to my kids
i'm trying to be informed yeah well and
so uh we can talk about that here in a
minute um there's some context but it
there is some
healing that can happen right so it's
it's not
um it's
you're on a track but it's not
predetermined right which is cool that's
the beauty of this stuff that the
earlier you see it and earlier you find
it and the the more healing you're a
part of um the you can change some of
those things
um
so you grow up in this situation how do
you end up
a stable mom
what the world did how did you end up
here
ms and we're always asked that and i
think
our families were so bad or so
dysfunctional that we looked around for
who had it right and what we really
wanted and how different we wanted it to
be
so i really really focused in on school
and made sure that i was getting out and
getting and going to college and i
watched people that i saw you know and
this is silly i watched sitcoms how
might families interact how might this
work um and then you watch other people
that you've seen around you know other
families and how do they talk to each
other and then i read a lot a lot of
books
on kind of how
maybe
families and people should interact
but you just described to me very
intellectual exercises you read a lot
you watched a lot
that's different than putting this into
practice
something you you chose a different life
in a very difficult set of circumstances
how did you do that
i
emotionally i i'm i don't know that i
have a great answer i can tell you that
i i came across this really nice guy
when i was just starting off for college
and i ended up marrying him and he's
stable and he's caring and his family is
you know
wonderful and great examples and i am
blessed to have had some great
friendships
that
were around me so i may not have had
family support
but i had friends and men had some
really strong friendships and then a
very strong
caring
boyfriend slash husband so a hundred
percent of the time when somebody makes
a transition out of the life
circumstance you have and yours is
bananas right yours is one that that um
is not the norm
but when you if we back it way up right
and we look at kids who grew up in
tumultuous relationships or in the home
of an addict which you did both or the
home of a parent with mental illness
which you did
home of abuse and we could probably go
down that rabbit hole and you've seen
and experienced that and and and
a hundred percent of the time
healing starts and begins with
relationships
somebody somewhere some group some
community somebody
they find they get connected to right
whether it's some cute guy that you
ended up marrying well played by the way
and he won the lottery marrying you
and a group of friends and then that
starts a healing process that's in your
body can finally start to turn down
those trauma alarms that says you're
disconnected which is awesome
so you find yourself here
how old are your kids now
i have 16 year old twins
[Laughter]
you know what because why not
six months why not man
what do you do for a living i'm a bank
manager what about your husband what's
he do
i tea
so we're vanilla i was gonna say
someone would just see you in the
grocery store and they'd look at your
twins and go wow you that was pretty
tough and you just smile at him and go
oh honey you have no idea
that's very true they have no idea wow
and and and that's okay because the goal
is to
have
the kids understand but not live it yeah
and that's that's the hard trick and it
is hard to separate because she's
you know the they want to hear the
stories they don't want to hear the
stories and sometimes i'm not ready to
or not sure that they even should hear
which parts of this still hang on to you
meaning
regardless of the amount of work you do
there is still parts of your body that
are scanning the environment 24 7 365.
and that end up if you have a legacy of
childhood trauma like you experienced
that ultimately
is the
uh i hate using mechanical analogies but
that's ultimately the
what's got to be turned down right
that's what causes long-term body
inflammation that over time just wears
your body out right because it's
scanning 24 7 it never rests um what are
the things that still pop up in your
life that you have to be vigilant
about i
find that i want desperately to teach my
kids survival for their life
and
maybe a little bit more than other
parents for their age so
i have to tone down to make sure that
they still have that childhood and i'm
not
over preparing um
that that desperate need to make sure
they have
a knowledge of how to live and survive
you know that survival instinct
apparently still continues
my
very focused on
money and caring for and making sure
stability for food and i always fight a
food battle because we were hungry a lot
and
then making sure that monetarily even
though we've done well we follow dave
ramsey's plan we've done well it's still
hard to always feel
that
enough yeah yeah yeah feel that safe
that safety i think is always something
i gotta work on so it doesn't surprise
me at all that someone who has worked
really hard to heal and to change their
entire
family tree
becomes a banker
stable control right there is a
spreadsheet that i can know is that
are those numbers on this side of the
ledger red or black right it's it is it
it's a beautiful testament to how you've
wrapped up the world and said
i'm going to control what i can control
and then those tendencies i i bet
there's moments of peace when you have a
full refrigerator right or every month
when you get that email that says your
check has been automatically deposited
i would almost be willing to bet if we
had a heart tracker on you that your
body would settle for a second
right and then over time it slowly ramps
back up until two weeks later when you
get that next check and you go
right and it's
working on that constantly over time
golly you're incredible all right so
what we can do we take a quick break
when we come back we're going to talk
about the situation you find yourself in
which is how do you care for a mom
who was a
played a significant role in your
childhood trauma and you got a context
you know where her trauma comes from
and still
that's a fireball right so stay tuned
we'll be right back on the dr john
dolone show
[Music]
all right i want to take a quick break
and answer one of the most common
questions i get deloney i can't find a
counselor in my area or i can't afford
one listen help is here i've partnered
with better help for customized online
therapy for you video therapy phone
therapy or you can even text with a
licensed therapist in your area or
somewhere across the country to get the
help that you need when you need it go
to
delony betterhelp.com 10 off your first
month listen online therapy is less
expensive than in-person therapy i've
taken away all of your excuses
now you have to recognize you're worth
being well go see a counselor online
with betterhelp.com today
all right sherry we're back
hey first
thank you just for talking about your
childhood i know that's not super fun
thing to do early in the morning
on a whatever day this happens to be
so now we're going to fast forward you
just to recap you grew up in the home of
a
nazi holocaust survivor
your mom was born in a barn
to grandparents who were hiding because
they were being hunted by their
neighbors they were being hunted by the
police officers those who were supposed
to protect them and serve them
they ultimately went from house to house
and had to reconnect with whoever
happened to be still alive
then over time
they
just said wherever there is is better
than here they got on a boat immigrated
to america
america was a welcoming place in that
there was a port
but they didn't know the language they
didn't have jobs um
jewish immigrants were treated like
garbage when they got here
and your parents and your
your dad went to just work right he just
went to work and had cousins that tagged
along
and then your mom's born in this mess
and she's got some significant mental
health challenges she always has she's
she demonstrated what i would call
normal
survival behavior which is
going from relationship to relationship
and always trying to make sure there's
food and that turns into some
pathological behaviors
and then you and your brothers are born
into this
and you're raised in a very traumatic
household with addiction and abuse and
go on and on and on and then
your mother is in how old is she now
76. okay so she's getting to the end
here and
she's got some health challenges
and you are responsible for taking care
of her and giving her
twilight years
of
respect and dignity and it's
wearing on your soul tell me about that
it's
hard to
to care for someone that didn't care for
you and and and we often say that she's
very nice but she's you know in that
crazy form at night
she she does everything she can to not
acknowledge past not just you know
childhood but everything so then but
that includes my childhood there is no
stories of when i was younger there is
no reminiscing
i am a caretaker to her i exist and so i
didn't have
the mom that i see
my mother-in-law being and i didn't have
the or that i want to be for my
daughters and there's
it's hard because she wants connection
quite regularly
and
i don't feel that connection in the way
and other people can't imagine that they
assume everyone loves their mother
everyone loves and everyone
and i have some cultural and religious
obligations that to care for her but
that resentment is so strong and i
she just had a manic delusion where she
you know she just lost some her
connection to reality recently and
called the police to the nursing home to
say that the aides were fighting
so you know i was hoping she doesn't get
kicked out of places for some of these
delusional
behaviors so she's
she's very nice so she's very mentally
ill and it's
now that my daughters i've asked them to
help a little bit and i'm realizing that
that's really scary what's normal to me
is very scary to them right
so how far do you want to dig in here
let me ask you the overarching question
is how can i help
when you have individuals there's
probably there's got to be thousands and
thousands of people that have mentally
ill parents
and it really isn't something we talk
about we don't really discuss
that
and
maybe some
how how do i reconcile that feeling of
resentment and
to be able to
take that logic of understanding their
trauma and be more compassionate and
more empathetic
might build that empathy back great
question there
um
so a couple of things here number one i
would let the
the
uh
it's necessary it's normal and it can
wear you out
i would let go
any trying to put puzzle pieces together
of an origin story here
okay
the well i think the the schizophrenia
came from here and the bipolar ki
i would let that past part go
because all it does is it it adds
mental anguish it adds bricks in your
backpack that are unnecessary
right now you found yourself here
and
have you ever have you ever sat down and
forgiven your mom
have you gone through a process to just
forgive your mom
i don't think i have i don't think you
have either
and when you're
you're carrying that around you're
carrying around the fact that
your mom stole your childhood you're
carrying around the fact that your
childhood didn't every time you're
around your husband's family you both
love it
and it pisses you off
because you should have had that and you
didn't
and every time your mother-in-law is
pretty awesome
yeah yeah every time you're with her
it's incredible because you get that
maternal care that you never got and it
burns a hole in your soul because you
should have got it right
is that right
yeah you're right jerry you should have
had a mother who loved you you should
have had a mother who looked you in the
eye and said you have value and she
hugged you a lot and she was stable and
you never had to worry about food
and you didn't
but the problem now is you're still
carrying that resentment and you've
mentioned it like how do i man how do i
get out of this resentment
that the easiest way to get out of
resentment is forgiveness
and forgiveness is hard
and you're right it doesn't have to be a
survivor of a holocaust it doesn't have
what i would tell you is this even if
there was not the legacy of trauma that
your mom endured because we can look at
this and say yeah i can see that totally
right
um
even if your mother was just mean
she just grew up in a normal house in
alabama and she just grew up mean and
treated her kids like trash
you as a 45 year old or a 40 year old or
how old you are
you carrying that
does not affect your mom in any way
it just affects you
and it just affects your kids and it
just affects your marriage
and so the day you decide
i'm not gonna carry that
i'm not gonna carry her stuff anymore
this happened to me
it will always be something i wish was
different
and then i'm gonna put a period at the
end of that and then i'm gonna write the
next sentence going forward and that
sounds so trite
but if you think of it literally what i
would love for you to do is to go out
get a buy a cinder block like at home
depot or something
and write it down
right on like maybe put duct tape on
there or something that you can write
some things on that block and i want you
just to carry it around your house for a
while
like
physically hold it
and then i want you to go in the yard
and just set it down on the ground
and there's some sort of physical
representation here like i'm not going
to carry what my mom did or didn't do
for us as ch as children
and trying to figure it out and
understand it you can't understand that
sort of evil and madness of nazi
occupation
and if if you're listening to this show
and you're like well i don't know i want
you to go read about it because nazis
get thrown around a lot these days
most people have no idea the depth of
evil that was going on
and um
but there's something for you just to
set it down
and then
there's a couple of things you've
mentioned here can you can you forgive
her maybe you can't can you
i i think she deserves it
forgiveness is for you
forgiveness is a decision on your part
that i'm not going to carry this anymore
and i think i i deserve it then yeah
there you go
i think you do too
i think on the scope of
um
like while we're why why i don't know
when this episode will come out but
while we're filming we're in the middle
of the olympics right we talk about
heroes and rock stars and look at these
extraordinary people
nobody will understand the depth of
extraordinary heroes
until they've sat in your shoes
because you stared down on a forest fire
of generational trauma and you said no
more and when somebody does that they
usually end up with third degree burns
all over themselves but their kids don't
and that's you
that's my greatest wish it's not a wish
you're doing it you're doing it right
now
what would be extraordinary
your daughters are 16
yeah they're old enough
they're old enough to have conversations
whether that's watching taking them and
doing something like watching
schindler's list together or um
taking them and reading a book and then
just saying hey here's here's where
grandma grew up
and this is how generational trauma
works and this is where we find
ourselves
and you could walk them through the aces
test that you took
and you don't have to be graphic
at some point when they're in their 20s
or 30s they're going to want to know
where they came from and some of those
stories as you're able to talk about
them you can
but
this is part of their generation too
this is part of their legacy too
and
man what a gift you talk about a gift
you give your kids
is watching them
watch
watch letting them watch you go through
the forgiveness process
i'm putting it down
i'm going to set this down i'm not going
to carry it
and then they get to see
here's what dignity and respect look
like
because at some point yes your mom needs
care she does
but more than that you need to care for
your mom and you know that and i think
that's what's killing you
is that fair
yeah i don't think you could not care
for your mom
no i can't there you go
and
revenge
what is it revenge neglect is not a
thing
you won't feel good right
that would perpetuate your family trauma
further
to say you were mean to me mom i'm not
caring for you i'm going to turn you
over to government resources and best of
luck to you
you know what i mean and i i know they
are psychotic delusions that she's
experiencing
when she calls the police and thinks the
police are coming together
she's also seen that with her own eyes
and that's a different level of delusion
does that make sense
yes she's got traumatic memories in her
body and her brain and in her heart and
in her mind and in her spirit she's seen
those things
and so it's it's like when you if you
were to
be in the woods and a tiger jumps out
20 years later if you flinch every time
you see a shadow
i can say man that's crazy what are you
doing
but i also understand right and so i
trying to classify is that a delusion is
that great
man
i'm just going to put that mental energy
down i'm just not going to carry that
stuff around anymore
but i want you to forgive your mom i
think you i love that you said that you
deserve to forgive your mom you deserve
to not carry this anymore and then you
deserve to teach your daughters
here's what
dignity looks like for me for my
children for my family and for my mom
and every time you think
i should have had this as a kid you can
go yeah i should have
and i'm gonna make sure my daughters get
it right and that way you don't stew on
that thing you don't ruminate on what
you missed there's a period at the end
of that sentence because you can't go
back and edit it you can't go back and
change it so ruminating on it doesn't do
anything other than send your body back
into fight or flight back into anger
back into frustration
and i love
i've completely shifted my
definition of trauma based off peter
levine's work and bessel vanderkolk's
work
trauma isn't what happened it's not the
bad ugly stuff that happened in our past
it's our bodies remembering
of those things in the present
and so when you think about what
happened to you as a kid and your heart
rate takes off on you that's the trauma
that's what you're looking to heal that
you can remember those things
and your heart rate doesn't pick up on
you
that you're that that's healing the aces
stuff right that's healing the adverse
childhood experiences that your body
doesn't respond in a flame state anymore
because
am i carrying that crap around anymore
yep that happened that's a fact and then
there's a period
because we're creating something new
do you think you can do that
i can i can do it i a hundred percent no
you can
and there will come a season when you'll
make meaning of this that's not today
but you'll make meaning of this here's
what i would love it'd be an honor
i'd love for you to sit down with your
daughters and talk about that cinder
block put some masking tape on it or
some duct tape on it and write it down
i'd love for you to take a picture of
that and email it to us
okay i can do that
write down the things that should have
happened that didn't happen here's what
it was like growing up with mom
and
i think it's not bad for your
grandmother i mean for your mom to scare
your daughters a little bit
not terrorize them right and if she's
swinging at them or screaming at him i
mean that's scary
but i think it's okay for them to see
mom's not well
and here's what i'm gonna do in light of
that
oh my gosh you're talking about changing
generations that's it
and you are standing in the gap you
asked for none of this you deserve none
of this but here you are
and if the world had more people like
you willing to stand in the gap and
saying i didn't cause this but i'm in it
and i'm gonna turn the page
the whole world shifts sherry
you're one of the bravest most
extraordinary women i've ever had the
opportunity to talk to and i'm grateful
that you have blessed me and this
audience for telling your story
man and what's cool about you is your
story still getting rolling
right
yeah
absolutely what a gift
thank you thank you thank you for
sharing with us take a picture of that
brick spend some time carrying it around
maybe even have your daughters carry it
for a minute
maybe even your husband is involved in
this thing but this is a family event
where we're forgiven grandma
and then we're going to decide how we're
going to take care of her how we're
going to love her we're not going to
live in resentment we're going to choose
to not live in resentment because all
resentment does is burn your house down
nobody else's right
and then we're going to talk about
here's what dignity and respect looks
like for all of us moving forward
wow you're incredible thank you so so
much for your call for your heart i
can't wait to get that picture
i might even show that picture to my
family that's incredible sherry you're a
saint thank you so so much for your call
hey as we wrap up today's show
um we took a longer time with that one
that was a deep dive call and um there's
a lot there
if you don't know
about the horrors of nazi germany go get
a book and read don't google it go get
some books there's plenty of them
you will stop throwing that around
that was a harrowing evil time in our
world's history
and it will also help you be vigilant
about what the history looks like moving
forward
and if you are with people in your life
whether your parents were addicts or
whether they were
overweight or whether they got fired a
lot or whatever
what i'll tell you as an adult you're 20
year old you're 35 you're 45 you're 65
listening to this show
carrying that around
does nothing but burden
and there is
healing from that there is peace from
that and it is more complicated often
than just dropping a break down in your
yard i get that
many people need to go to therapy go to
counseling and go to betterhelp.com you
can pick up you can if you can't find a
counselor you can find a trauma
counselor
relationships relationships moving your
body sleep all these things right they
all work together
but you can't heal
you can reverse some of this aces
trajectory where that is going to
guarantee you have a higher rate of of
physical
harm and cancer and strokes and heart
attacks and all those kind you can turn
the corner on those things
but it starts with you saying i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna carry this around
anymore i'm gonna forgive because i
deserve it
i'm not gonna live in resentment and
we're gonna go be about healing
thank you so much for being a part of
the show today all right as we as we get
out of here
man what perfect song perfect song for
today off the board and raised record
out in 2012.
it's one of my favorite songs in the
world john mayer's song the age of worry
and it goes like this close your eyes
and clone yourself and build your heart
and army to defend your innocence while
you do everything wrong don't be scared
to walk alone and don't be scared to
like it
there's no time that you must be home so
sleep where darkness falls alive in the
age of worry smile and age of worry go
wild in the age of worry and say worry
why should i care
dream your dreams but don't pretend to
make friends with what you are
give your heart then change your mind
you're allowed to do it because god
knows it's been done to you and somehow
you got through it
sing out in the age of worry and say
worry
why should i care
right here at dr john dorney's show